the shock of surviving and disbelief at
the devastation
the pain of losing a lifetime of hard
work in a matter of seconds
it was shortly after midnight when the
Missile hit the quiet street in the
nepro ripping apart homes and lives a
family of four were all killed instantly
Jenna picked up a picture from the
rubble a memory of neighbors gone too
early
they first found Allah the grandmother
then the mother and her daughter and
they had to search the rubble for the
sun we had fragments of a couch on our
roof and there were human remains burnt
on it I wasn't injured but I am scared
now each air siren will remind me of
this I will be scared each time it goes
off
it's not clear yet what kind of Missile
hit but it left the crater 10 meters
deep just a day ago a family home stood
here
four houses have been flattened and
another 60 damage this is a residential
neighborhood we don't see any military
presence in the area nor is there any
kind of infrastructure that could have
been targeted people are worried because
of recent the number of airstrikes has
increased
another airstrike targeted the bus
station a few meters away from the
central train station
there were also strikes in kharkiv in
the Northeast and several Southern
cities including privilege the hometown
of President Vladimir zielinsky
andrei's 80 year old mother was alone he
also can't believe she survived he's a
surgeon treating the wounded of this war
we live at a time when anything can
happen but after this nothing can scare
us what can be worse than your mother in
such danger in the middle of the night
we have all to lose if there's a nuclear
attack but we're just average people we
have no choice president zielinski held
an emergency meeting with his security
and defense cabinet the country is
holding his breath as Russia goes ahead
with its plans to Annex parts of Ukraine